okay now for our final speaker of the
day we were chatting after lunch uh we
think it was three or maybe four years
ago that she last
spoke for us and we're glad uh she could
come back
cheryl atkinson is a five-time emmy
award-winning investigative journalist
many of you know her as the managing
editor and host
of sinclair broadcast group's excellent
sunday morning news program full measure
previously she was a correspondent for
cbs news
and an anchor and correspondent for cnn
and i promised her we wouldn't hold that
last bit
about cnn against her in addition she
hosted health week
a weekly medical news magazine on pbs
in addition to her emmys her many other
awards include
the barbara olsen award for excellence
and independence
in journalism and the edward r moreau
award for excellence in
investigative reporting
somehow in the midst of her top-notch
reporting work
she finds time to write best-selling
books
the most recent of these is titled
slanted how the news media
taught us to love censorship and hate
journalism
she'll be drawing on themes from that
book in her talk today
would you please welcome back to the
podium cheryl atkinson
so good to be here in person
haven't been doing many in-person
appearances boy can you guys see me
i feel like i'm totally hidden
yeah if you guys have a stool if someone
has a small thing maybe you want to
bring it
okay i too have some slides that i can't
see at all from here
maybe i'll stand over here
now i'm messing up the camera shot well
i'll just stand on my toes a little bit
till we get a
stool but today i'm speaking about
let's see the first slide
journalism of the 2020 election slanted
journalism
and i hope you can take today's speech
maybe have a little fun with it because
as sad as these trends are
maybe when we talk about them together
and think about ways to
stay informed and address these things
we can at least
be entertained by some of the outrage
really that the news business has become
let's begin by tracing
the well-organized and well-funded
movement to corner the market on
information and narratives
this movement i think was designed
specifically
in part to keep president trump from
serving his full term
or if that failed to income impact the
2020 race
this whole strategy relied heavily on
slanted journalism
and that required major news outlets to
suspend their normal ethics and
guidelines
which astonishingly enough they did
unabashedly
and admitted to it outright saying that
it was necessary to change the way we do
business because
president trump was so uniquely
dangerous
so in the past few years we've
experienced a sea change in terms of how
the media
do their job the emergence of trump as a
viable political candidate
accelerated this devolution no longer do
reporters
as you know keep their opinions
firewalled from their stories their
stories are rife with their opinions
dubious anonymous sources are repeatedly
relied upon
even after they've repeatedly proven
shamefully unreliable
basic fact checks go unconducted as long
as the news furthers an
anti-trump narrative egregious reporting
mistakes and we'll talk about some of
those today
are made by the same outlets and
sometimes the same
reporters over and over again and yet
are magically forgiven
journalism ethical standards are bent or
suspended so that trump could be covered
more aggressively and
in a one-sided fashion
some of the best evidence for this can
be found in a june 2017 opinion piece by
a guy named mitchell stevens
and was published in politico stevens is
a journalism professor
at new york university in his article he
cheers on the end of media objectivity
hold on just a moment we may have a
solution here
thank you
thank you much better thank you okay
i'll be careful
thank you so he cheers on the end of
media objectivity under a new president
trump
who was under attack by the media the
headline to his
article was goodbye nonpartisan
journalism and good riddance
disinterested reporting is overrated
it's shocking that a journalism
professor someone teaching up and coming
professionals in the field of news
considers disinterested reporting to be
overrated
disinterested reporting was i thought
always thought of as a pillar of good
journalism
tossing it aside is i think a bit like a
medical school professor
telling medical students that diet and
exercise are overrated
in fact they're fundamental neutrality
and objectivity and news reporting are
fundamental
but if one we're trying to brainwash
people into thinking
journalism is really about the opposite
thing then yes
one would say the fundamentals are
outdated and to be rejected
stevens goes on in his very partisan
peace do he prays upon the new york
times's public descent
into blatant partisanship he writes
our most respected mainstream journalism
organizations are beginning to recognize
the failings of nonpartisanship
its tepidness its blind spots its
omissions its evasions
he says it was news when the patriarch
of american journalism the new york
times
finally used the word lie in a headline
atop its front page
september 17 2016 to describe a trump
assertion
stevens goes on to note with
satisfaction that other legacy media
followed suit
he wrote other legacy journalism
organizations began more regularly
calling out trump's falsehoods if not
actually accusing him of lying about a
week later
the los angeles times declared also on
page one
never in modern presidential politics
has a major candidate made false
statements
as routinely as trump has
on april 5th 2017 the new york times
reflecting the new world order
quickly changed a headline from trump
says susan rice may have committed a
crime
to trump citing no evidence
suggests susan rice committed a crime
anchorman scott pelley at cbs upped the
ante by calling trump's statements
divorced from reality no attribution
just pele's
own critical opinion so what the
journalism professor stephen sees as
worthy of a claim
i see is irresponsible a journalism
professor is teaching a new generation
of reporters
to inject agendas and opinions in their
reporting
to forget about the firewall that we
used to attempt to put
between news and opinion that kind of
reporting
that stevens applauds would have gotten
a traditional news journalist fired
not all that long ago today it's part of
what makes it so easy for the narrative
to take hold
and can make it so difficult for the
truth to be told
there's endless evidence for this sort
of slanted reporting today
little quiz for you
based on this headline in the atlantic
who would you guess
came out on top in a september 2019
election in north carolina democrats or
republicans it says
north carolina gives republicans a
wake-up call
the results of a special election
portend trouble for the gop
in 2020. sure sounds as though
republicans got their clocks cleaned
after all the headlines states they got
a wake-up call and the results portend
trouble for the gop
so you might be surprised to learn as i
was that
the republicans actually had a
successful night
it's laid out right there in the article
if you get past the misleading headline
boop
here we go in a congressional race
the republican candidate beat the
democrat by a far
wider margin it says of 4 000 votes
and separately in a state special
election republican greg murphy won as
expected
how on earth did those republican
victories elicit a headline
implying that the republican had lost
it's as if somebody was bent on pushing
a particular narrative regardless
of how the actual election turned out
in this way we can see how reporters who
are pushing a narrative don't care much
about the facts
pesky facts that contradict a narrative
are nothing more than a nuisance to
brush off reporters simply devise
ways to dispense of them
another example demonstrates nearly
every trademark
of a narrative and the perils that come
with reporters advancing it blindly
on april 15 2020 politico reports that
president trump
owed the bank of china tens of millions
of dollars
in a loan coming due in 2022 as he dealt
with china
on the coronavirus pandemic the
implication there is that trump
can't be as tough as he needs to be on
china
and chinese leaders for unleashing cove
at 19 and covering up its seriousness
because he is beholden to them this
news makes headlines around the world
trump owes tens of millions to the bank
of china and the loan is due
soon blair's the headline on politico
donald trump's debt to china reads the
new york times's headline
and national review trump owes millions
to bank of china for building loan
reports show
but it isn't true shortly after this
news circled the earth the bank of china
issued a statement saying
it had held that trump loan only for 22
days
before selling it to a u.s real estate
firm in 2012.
in other words tens of millions of
dollars that trump supposedly owed china
due soon was actually owed for only
three weeks back in 2012
eight years before
obviously these facts negate the whole
idea behind the story but the media are
not about to admit that they made a
mistake
politico simply changes its headline
trump owes
to trump owed china past tense
they and the other media pretend the
false information they published had
little bearing on the actual news
national review likewise simply changes
trump owes
to trump owed politico could have
avoided the error
if it had hadn't failed to follow a
basic rule that's taught to every 19 and
20 year old
journalism student contact the people
you're talking about in a story before
you publish
pardon me of the three reporters by
lined in the article
mark caputo meredith mcgraw and anita
kumar none apparently thought to contact
the bank of china before publishing the
story
and apparently no editor thought it was
necessary to do so either
had they done their job they likely
would have learned prior to publication
as they were supposed to
that there was no current loan to trump
from china thus avoiding
their major flub
there are so many of these mistakes it
starts to look like a pattern
a strategy against trump not just sloppy
mistakes
and i tracked the major media mistakes
and never found one that
favored trump that starts to look like a
pattern too
on thanksgiving day 2019 little less
than a year from election day
we passed the 100th major media mistake
in the era of trump by my count
this error was committed by newsweek's
political reporter jessica quang
who wrote a story and published a tweet
asking how did trump spend thanksgiving
tweeting golfing and more she went on to
write that trump was spending
thanksgiving day
at his mar-a-lago resort in palm beach
florida the story implied that trump was
once again
goofing off compared to his heroic
predecessor president obama
who used to only do selfless things
the problem is her story was false
trump had actually left florida the
evening before thanksgiving to fly to
afghanistan
where he spent the holiday not golfing
but serving dinner to us
troops
[Applause]
when her mistake became clear the
reporter kwong claimed she'd made an
honest mistake
on twitter she wrote that she was
deleting her earlier incorrect tweet
with fabricated information about trump
because
quote it was written before knowing
about the president's surprise visit to
afghanistan
there are five key problems with this
explanation from an ethical standpoint
journalism so i'm going to go over those
first
she demonstrated a la a shocking lack of
repertorial knowledge
i'm not a political reporter nor do i
closely follow the white house yet
i knew enough to wonder whether on a
holiday the president might be making a
surprise visit to
the troops on thanksgiving because all
recent presidents have done this at one
time or another
one would think a national political
reporter and her editors would know
to watch for a possible surprise visit
by the president
second that newsweek article
demonstrated an inexcusable failure to
attribute
quang's mistake wouldn't have been as
problematic if she had attributed
the claim that trump was golfing on
thanksgiving to an actual source instead
of reporting it
as if it were her own first-hand
confirmed information
huang isn't the only one who seems to
have abandoned the basic journalistic
practice of attributing information to
its source
reporters now routinely declare
information to be a fact as if they have
personally confirmed it
when they could not possibly have done
so there was no election fraud or
there wasn't enough to change the
outcome of the election
the reporters claiming these things
haven't gone to any precincts
and examined records or interviewed
witnesses on the ground they're just
declaring something they want to believe
as a fact
third the problem with the newsweek
story there is a baffling failure to
fact check
this is one of the most basic tenets of
journalism no matter how obvious
something seems no matter how many
others are reporting it no matter how
obvious a video clip
may seem to show something it often
proves to be wrong
that's why it's so critical for
reporters to check their assumptions
huang should have contacted the white
house to see if her claim
that trump would be golfing on
thanksgiving was true
if the people there had said yes and she
attributed the answer to the white house
then even if trump had ended up in
afghanistan huang could not have been
journalistically faulted for the
mistaken information she would have
done her job correctly instead she
reported false information as if she had
checked it
fourth there was a glaring failure
to correct the mistake after the fact
although newsweek
fixed the story it didn't really correct
it editors called the revision an
update this is disingenuous the story
hadn't changed
or been updated newsweek simply learned
that its original report was false
that merits both a correction and an
apology
in fifth the false information persisted
well
after the update newsweek retained its
false headlines stating that trump
golfed on thanksgiving he didn't
i think that's still up there today
because i checked in the last week
[Applause]
i really think one of the most
remarkable things about this whole story
is that
it's a case of history repeating itself
it's an example of lessons not learned
by the media
nbc had generated a similar scandal less
than a year before
also tying itself up into a pretzel to
make it seem as if it had not bungled a
story
the nbc saga began on december 25th
2018. nearly eight hours before
christmas days official
end the timing matters you'll see why in
a moment
the network published a headline blaring
trump becomes
first president since 2002 not to visit
troops at christmas time
the story claimed that trump had broken
from a recent tradition
of actually visiting troops and wounded
warriors
the article took multiple jabs at trump
to advance the anti-trump narrative of a
president
who could not live up to the standards
of his predecessors
what nbc did not know was that contrary
to its reporting trump had left the
white house
late on december 25th
to visit the troops in iraq
what happened when the mistake was
revealed is quite telling
like newsweek nbc was unable to admit
its mistake
instead of a simple apology saying it
originally had no idea the president had
sneaked off to iraq
and that it had made an assumption
without bothering to verify it
nbc published a lengthy editor's note
parsing the definition of what
constitutes a christmas time visit
and claimed the original article was
technically correct
depends on what the meaning of the word
is is
okay so the nbc editor makes the
argument
well maybe trump visited the troops
around christmas after all and yes he
did leave the white house on christmas
to go to iraq
but he did not arrive in iraq until
after the stroke of midnight
and the day after christmas isn't really
a christmas time visit is it
so instead of an apology nbc defends it
mistake its mistake by arguing
when christmas time technically begins
and ends
the nbc's editor's note reads
this is so twisted as of the end of
christmas day
2018 trump had not visited the troops
during the holiday season
and had announced no plans to do so the
article was correct
but on december 26 the situation changed
trump and the first lady melania trump
made an unannounced visit to troops in
iraq
as a result the thrust of this article
is no longer correct
even if it was at the time in the
interest of transparency we are keeping
the article
on nbcnews.com so that the record will
reflect the situation on the day the
article was published
and are directing readers to an article
about trump's iraq visit here
we are also altering one line in the
article as well as the headline
to be more specific and to note trump
was the first president
since 2002 who didn't visit military
personnel
on or before christmas rather than at
christmas time
claiming the article was correct at the
time but the situation
changed without acknowledging the
journalistic malpractice at issue here
is remarkable
the corrected article then goes on to
double down on its mistake
in a way that's still designed to make
trump look bad
because after all that's the goal first
nbc chooses a new tack that fits the
narrative it set out to prove and stuck
by it regardless of the facts
by staying home on tuesday said nbc
trump became the first president since
2002
who didn't visit military personnel on
or before christmas
and then elaborates based on a check of
nbc logs
president barack obama visited troops at
marine corps base hawaii every christmas
he was in office
from from 2009 to 2016
before him said nbc according to a check
of news releases president george w
bush visited wounded warriors at walter
reed
from 2003 to 2008.
trump previously said nbc goes on to say
he hasn't visited a combat zone because
he's had an unbelievably busy schedule
among the anti-trump press
the new version of the story comparing
trump unfavorably to obama and bush goes
viral no attention is paid to nbc's
mistake
it's like it never even happened the
focus becomes the newly revised scandal
that trump is the first president
not to visit the troops on or before
christmas day
one exception to the groupthink which
surprised me
is the normally anti-trump eric whimple
of the washington post
he actually took issue with nbc pointing
out
trump didn't stay home christmas tuesday
as nbc claimed in the updated version of
its article at least not all of tuesday
he left the white house late on december
25th
whimple goes on to say the nbc story
appears to rest on a lawyerly definition
of christmas time christmas day in the
days and weeks before it
however other common definitions of
christmas time expand that understanding
to the christmas season
or the period from about december 24 to
january 1st
or january 6 but wimple says
nbc seemed intent on making the story be
about whether they could
technically defend that they hadn't
jumped the gun and made a false
assumption
rather than what trump actually did over
the christmas holiday
nbc could have chosen numerous facts to
highlight about president trump if it
were focused on disseminating
information rather than generating a
smear
so let's look at some of the actual
stats i found when i did a little
research
it turns out president obama never
visited u.s troops in foreign countries
or combat zones on thanksgiving or at
christmas time as trump had done twice
by early 2020
the closest president obama got to
spending thanksgiving or christmas in a
combat zone with the troops
was a visit to south korea a week before
thanksgiving in 2009
president bill clinton was kind of close
to a christmas visit
with a december 22nd 2007 visit to
bosnia but that was after the war ended
the annual christmas troops visit that
nbc rushed to
credit obama for all of those had taken
place
not in a combat zone but stateside
conveniently near obama's home in hawaii
not that there's anything wrong with
that but what i'm saying is if they
were looking to disseminate factual
information they could have come up with
an entirely different story
another point made in the slanted
nbc article about trump was
that he had yet to visit an active
combat zone as if it were an anomaly
that he supposedly had gone almost two
years without having done so
in fact according to military records
presidential visits to combat zones are
relatively rare
presidents have visited a combat zone
only 27 times
in u.s history prior to trump by early
2020
trump had added at least four to that
historic tally
visits to south korea iraq afghanistan
not to mention that he was sometimes
accompanied by first lady melania
who has made at least two visits to a
combat zone
i discovered another interesting point
while researching presidential trips to
combat zones
although you might not immediately think
of south korea as a combat zone
it technically is one because our war
with north korea was never officially
declared over
both north korea and the u.s which is
allied with south korea
patrol a demilitarized zone that divides
the two koreas
but remarkably when counting
obama's combat zone visits the military
and media
included his trips to south korea as
notches on his belt
but they did not count visits to the
same place for trump
at the very time when the press was
claiming trump had never visited a
combat zone
he had made two trips to south korea
punctuating the point
wikipedia whoops can i go
backwards
punctuating the point trump's wikipedia
page
claims that trump's first combat zone
visit
was on december 26 2018 to iraq
it too ignored his earlier visit to
south korea
in contrast the official tally for obama
counts all three of his trips to south
korea to
as combat zone visits apparently among
the slanted media
south korea is a combat zone when obama
visits but not when trump does
so here are seven other true headlines
that could have been written about
trump's christmas time visit to iraq
but weren't trump becomes first u.s
president in 16 years
to visit u.s troops in a combat zone
trump is one of only three u.s
presidents to spend thanksgiving day
with us troops in a combat zone melania
trump becomes the first
first lady to spend christmas time
visiting us troops in a war zone
trump is first president since george w
bush to spend thanksgiving with troops
in a foreign country
president trump is only the third u.s
president all of them republicans
to spend thanksgiving with u.s troops in
a combat zone or
u.s troops anywhere trump is the only
president to visit the troops in a
combat zone so close to christmas day
and president trump is the only u.s
president in history
to visit u.s troops both in a combat
zone on thanksgiving and so close to
christmas
so this deep dive into just a couple of
specific cases demonstrates
i think quite clearly how the media has
changed the way it operates
largely as i described in my last book
the smear
because the media has been successfully
influenced and in fact
infiltrated by corporate and political
interests
this explains why it's no mystery and no
accident the devolution of the news as i
call it
is by design and it ties in quite
directly to this accelerated and
dangerous trend towards censorship we've
seen the past four years but in
particular
i'd say the last six months
i'll summarize by saying on the
censorship trend
in 2016 by that time the news landscape
in my
view had largely been dominated by
political and corporate interests who
were defining the terms of what we could
and couldn't report about
the language that we had to use and the
kind of people we could interview
but these people saw that trump got
elected anyway in 2016
despite the fact that most of the media
had told people not to vote for him and
that he was inherently dangerous
so these people seeking to influence the
information landscape
they blame the internet they thought
that people
were largely controlled in the news that
they could get but we could still go
online and get other opinions see other
scientific studies hear other viewpoints
so they said about i think spending the
last four years trying to figure out how
to control the internet
and if you remember before 2016 big tech
did not have
great interest in this sort of
censorship there were issues with
privacy
and other problems but they were not
doing what we what i call
fake fact checks they were not censoring
accounts
and interfering between us and our
information to tell us what we can and
cannot believe
now fact checks whether they're done by
non-profits or newsrooms
are largely funded and influenced by
political incorporaters who want to
control that information
and in fact david brock of media matters
the propaganda group took credit for
convincing facebook right after the 2016
election
to start up those fake fact checks this
was a lobbying campaign
fact checks now become simply another
tool of propagandists
how do we fight censorship well when a
person or idea
is fact checked or banned or censored
or controversialized i think we should
make it our mission to find out more
about whatever's being censored
and asked the question why do powerful
interests not want me to have this
information
and make up my own mind
okay our final examination of how the
media changed the way it operated
to impact the 2020 election and control
narratives looks at
the verbiage of the narrative
before trump we as news reporters might
have pointed out discrepancies or
contradictions
between claims made by news maker and
facts
we might have noted that a statement or
a claim was disputed
or that it had proven incorrect or false
but we did not declare newsmakers
statements to be lies
why avoid using the l word in news
reporting well
a lie is a very specific thing and short
of the confession
it requires a reporter to claim to know
what's inside the mind of the person
speaking
in fact when somebody gives
contradictory information or makes a
false
statement it could theoretically be for
many other reasons
let's go back to the ford and fire
firestone tire rollover scandal in 2000
i covered a lot of stories where the
executives of these corporations said
there was no
evidence that there was danger they had
no realization that the tires had a
safety issue
but that contradicted documents that we
had that showed they had discussed this
long ago
it's a well-documented trail but i never
said they were liars
it's possible theoretically that their
staff gave them poor briefings
or withheld information or they might
have seen the documents in question but
misinterpreted them
or forgotten what they said as unlikely
as those excuses might seem it's not the
place of a news journalist to claim to
know what's in a person's mind
in fact there are very few instances i
can think of where
it's appropriate for a reporter in a
news report to claim that a newsmaker
lied
there's another important reason to be
circumspect as a news journalist with
accusing people of lies
to the news consumer such language tends
to sound as if the reporter is being
biased or pejorative
it begins to feel very personal it
removes the sense of neutrality that we
try to maintain in our heart news
reporting
in order to be seen as fair reporters of
fact it's best to stick to the facts
and let members of the public form their
own conclusions
the good practices that i've described
the reluctance to pretend to see inside
the mind of the subjects we report on
used to be considered the norm in
journalism but all of that has gone out
the window
now reporters frequently take sides
boldly declaring
one side or one newsmaker to be telling
the truth
and another usually trump to be lying
even when the truth is unproven or
impossible to know
or when the differences are matters of
interpretation or clashing opinions
or even when the lies or exaggerations
are misstatements
the new york times as i mentioned has
led the way in declaring itself
arbiters of trump's lies and if we've
seen other media quickly followed suit
and biased observers heralded it all as
brave and groundbreaking
so yesterday i conducted a google search
using the term obama lies
and it produced 41 million results i
then searched the term trump lies
that returns 612 million results
in other words after one term trump got
about 15
times more search results about lies
than obama had after two terms
a closer analysis shows that many of
trump's internet hits
about lies are links to news stories and
blogs and lists of his lies
and in contrast obama's hits to many of
his articles or blogs
were defending him against accusations
of lies or
with obama officials accusing trump of
lying
instead of providing critical push back
to this questionable journalistic shift
in which reporters call opinions of
their enemies or opinions they disagree
with lies
columbia journalism review jumped on the
bandwagon patting the new york times on
the back for calling trump a liar
a precedent has been set declared
columbia journalism review
approvingly which is great
columbia jerusalem review goes on to say
by using a word that comes from the
vocabulary of
advocacy in its own voice the times and
other news organizations have taken the
truth-telling standards of the news
business to a new level
until the rise of trump they say only on
rare occasions
criminal convictions and instances of
plagiarism and falsifying resumes
were words like lie ever used by the
media describing news events
i'm taken aback to see a journalism
review publication explicitly applauding
a news organization
for using the vocabulary of advocacy in
its news reporting
author and former new york times
reporter david k johnston
a pulitzer prize winner is quoted as
saying he was thrilled and flabbergasted
to see the times call trump a liar
why would that be a thrill unless one is
steeped and biased and seeking to
advance the narrative rather than report
the facts
with hearty support from journalism
groups and their peers it's
understandable that reporters
would grow even bolder they began to
expand the lie label
to cases when targeted newsmakers are
simply exaggerating
joking or misspeaking or when there's no
possible way to know for sure whether a
statement's true or false
one example can be found in news reports
declaring
trump was lying when he stated there was
fraud in the 2020 election or that the
election was stolen
unless one can somehow prove that trump
does not believe the election was stolen
but is saying it was
that wasn't a lie whether you like trump
or not
this is poor journalistic practice and
further erodes our credibility
as an industry another example
trump's 2019 state of the union address
when the president claimed our brave
troops have now been fighting in the
middle east for almost 19 years
the media's eagle-eyed fact-checkers
called that a lie
the actual length of time the u.s had
been fighting in the mideast they
countered
was not almost 19 years but a bit more
than 17.
actually the media's own fact check
about the length of the afghan war
could be characterized as a lie by its
own standard
the war began in october 2001
the state of the union address in
question took place more than
18 years later closer to trump's
almost 19 years than the media's 17
years
but that doesn't fit the trump is a liar
narrative
there's a second set of news phrases the
media invented and deployed
specifically against trump without
evidence
no credible evidence and no evidence
first without evidence as a news
journalist i don't recall ever using or
uttering the phrase without evidence
when reporting on anybody or anything
over the course of about 35 years
until we covered trump at first glance
it might seem as though phrases like
without evidence and no credible
evidence
are more fact-based and responsible than
tossing around accusations
of lies that they can be just as
problematic
who decides what evidence is credible
an absence of evidence does not
necessarily mean a claim is discredited
after all there is no evidence that
polio could be transmitted via water
or through the oral polio vaccine until
there was
there was no evidence that some
cholesterol is good for your health
until there was
without evidence is an invented concept
for the purpose of slanted reporting
consider that throughout time few
newsmakers have presented evidence when
making statements
it was never expected that each comment
or speech would be accompanied by a set
of footnotes or citations
until trump now without evidence is
commonly invoked in a one-sided fashion
usually against trump and his supporters
and typically when the media want to
call them into question
or disparage them
when it comes to trump russia collusion
and other anti-trump narratives we in
the media allowed
two years of outlandish allegations to
be made virtually free of challenge
and without credible evidence many of
those claims proved to be untrue
and there were more trump may have not
paid any income taxes for decades if
ever he never really wanted to be
president
he's lying about immigration being a
problem he was russian president
vladimir putin stooge a spy for russia
the list goes on at the same time we're
calling out trump
we're violating the very evidentiary
standards to which we hold him
in our zeal to get trump we are letting
our own journalistic principles slide
we've laid bare our own bias
and our own double standards we can
blame trump all we like for the death of
the news as we once knew it
but the truth is we've done it to
ourselves
if you're interested my book slanted
goes in far more depth about all of this
i interviewed a lot of colleagues and
top network news executives
and there's an appendix that lists the
media mistakes that i categorize one by
one
the mistakes made against trump when
reporters get caught doing bad
journalism
like i've described today they and their
colleagues often retort that
trump lied more than we do or
trump mocks the media and his enemies on
twitter before he was banned
the fact is trump mercilessly mocks and
is mercilessly mocked by his political
detractors
such as leading congressional democrats
nancy pelosi chuck schumer adam schiff
collectively political figures have no
obligation to be neutral or fair in fact
the nature of politics breeds this kind
of dynamic
but journalists are different our
professional obligation is to cover our
subjects fairly
we must maintain the same high standard
even when we don't like somebody we're
covering
especially perhaps when we don't like
that person
otherwise why have standards at all the
implication that somehow the media's
mistakes and attacks are justified
because of what we believe to be the
flawed moral character of our subject
is a precarious one the way we cover
those we perceive as the enemies of our
own viewpoints
defines how well we do our job covering
the news
and i'm happy to take some questions
[Applause]
thank you miss atkinson uh if you have a
question please raise your hand
and wait for a microphone to be brought
to you
could you please comment on the
influence of the pointer institute in
journalism
yes the pointer institute i've i've
discussed some of that in my book
slanted like the columbia journalism
review
and a lot of other non-profits or
journalism organizations
they've all been co-opted to some degree
by the same
political or corporate interests
accepting funding from the same handful
of dubious sources in my view
partisan sources that fund the fact
checks
whether it's on social media or news
organizations or these non-profits
it's the same group of people and you
can see the change in their reporting
maybe now pointer institute
relies on media matters this is one
example
as a source without in its writing
without disclosing that media matters is
a partisan propaganda group
and so young people are learning this
from them because
they're told to look to point our
institute as a standard in journalism
and ethics
so there's a problem from virtually
every angle we're looking when it comes
to journalism the
organizations that are supposed to help
watch over us
or set standards for the kind of
reporting we do they're cheering on this
trend that i'm talking about
there's a question to the speakers right
yes
what do the people who are writing the
slanted news
hope to gain
it's a mix you know it's a complicated
question because
in some instances there are more
traditional news journalists who are
censoring themselves and shaping what
they report because they're rewarded for
it
they're moving up in the hierarchy of
the newsroom when they
embrace this sort of reporting and
they're not rewarded
when they're not doing so so there's an
element of
people transforming themselves to keep
their job and advance their careers
but i think one of the bigger factors is
the trend i described
where propagandists political and
corporate interests
have infiltrated the news not just
figuring out how to influence what we
report
and lobbyists and send us by way of
third parties and non-profits
um talking points and things that are
supposed to be news that we then pick up
they now work for us in our newsrooms we
hire them
as editorial people we bring them on as
analysts and pay them six figure
salaries and then
you know they should be paying us to
appear on our air and distribute their
talking points but we're paying
paying them handsomely to do so so i
think um
you know the news business has been
transformed we're now there's no
firewall between
us and the interest trying to slant the
news
because they have a whole different goal
in mind we're one in the same
and that explains and really is the only
thing that explains why
so many formerly well-respected news
organizations
are getting so much wrong and yet
there's very little repercussion for
that kind of reporting the people who do
those stories
continue to be reported and heralded and
given awards and so on because
we now are them we're one in the same as
the propagandists in many instances
we have a question on the speaker's left
ma'am would you please comment on the
massive collusion between the mainstream
media the social media
and a number of government agencies to
totally censor
the hunter biden corruption scandal that
was first broken
by the new york post and what his
possible
implications were for the election
outcome
well i can't say what would have
happened although there's been some
polling done
talking about what could have influenced
the election
if this news had gotten out and i'll
point out one thing the new york post
didn't really break that story the
hunter biden story was
well fleshed out and discussed by
liberal news outlets the fall
before before biden was the democrats
nominee
there were i take it other democrats
that were planting stories in the press
to try to keep biden from being the
nominee and so let some in the
left-leaning press did some very good
and important expose
on the hunter biden alleged conflicts of
interest as well as other members of the
biden family
but once biden became the nominee fast
forward to the story sort of resurfacing
with news of his
computer being confiscated by the fbi
and all of a sudden everybody acted like
it was the first they'd heard of it
and then many on the left acted like it
was a conspiracy theory even though they
had well reported on this some months
before
and it's just the craziest dynamic glenn
greenwald of the intercept
who's a left-leaning reporter who thinks
much like i do about
news news and news trends he started the
intercept
with the goal in mind of having a news
organization that would not be beholden
to political and corporate interests in
the same way as what we call legacy
media
and you may know that glenn greenwald
quit his own news organization because
they censored his story on hunter biden
this is not just a problem of the left
you know versus right there's just a
problem in general by those seeking to
manage the news it's not always along
partisan lines
again i think we're left to guess what
impact it might have had on the election
we have a question on the speaker's
right
do the news reporters particularly the
tv reporters
actually believe what they're reporting
or are they simply
following what they're told to do from
higher ups
and then secondly how do corporate
interests which you mentioned
gain from false news
if i forget your second question remind
me in a minute but
i get asked all the time whether
reporters believe what they're talking
about especially when it's
proven later to be wildly wrong or when
it's very biased
and again i think that's a mixed answer
i think that um
i know some of the reporters involved
that you would think are very biased who
used to be fairly straight news
reporters
but they've gone to a news organization
where
there's a powerful dynamic of group
think and peer pressure
where the bosses want a certain kind of
reporting and when you deliver that
you're surrounded by people who pat you
on the back and tell you how brilliant
you are
and maybe you were not considered really
above app
too far above average in the old dynamic
but now you're a big star
because of all these kinds of things
you're reporting so i don't know if they
become a believer in
giving their own opinion and thinking
that it's valuable and even when proven
wrong
if they have a way to sort of justify
because they don't get punished for and
they're still being rewarded by their
bosses
but then the second dynamic is and i
believe strongly in this
as i said we've hired these
propagandists they've found ways to be
hired in our newsrooms
so they don't think it's a mistake and
even if they know they're wrong
and even if they get caught after the
fact having disseminated false
information
they're not embarrassed because they
still accomplished their goal if they're
not journalists they're not trying to
tell the truth necessarily they're
trying to put forth a narrative
and if they succeeded at that even if
the narrative isn't true
they've still done their job the way
they hope to do it
in my view
does this not uh prove a president
trump's comment
not so much fake news but the news media
has become
truly enemy of the people
well that's for you to decide but i do
think he made a lot of good points
um and as i talked about in my last book
most of you may think president trump
thought up the phrase fake news in its
modern context that was a liberal
invention
and i traced that to september of 2016.
it was first used in its modern context
by
a non-profit called first draft and
shortly after that president obama gave
a speech at carnegie mellon in which he
suggested for the first time i ever
heard
that somebody needed to step in and
curate our information
start curating the internet in this wild
wild west media environment as he called
it
and i remember thinking at the time
nobody if you can take yourself back
just a couple years nobody was asking
for people
third parties to come in and censor and
curate our news
they had to create the appearance of a
demand for such a program
so that they could control the news so i
went back and looked at
seeing that there was some kind of
operation going on here who is first
draft
and i called this non-profit and said
where do you get your funding because
they hadn't filed tax forms yet
and they admitted that they got their
funding from google and they were
invented around the start of the
election cycle this non-profit that
invented the concept of going after fake
news which was just
defined at the time as cons mostly
conservative news
and google was owned is owned by
alphabet
who was led at the time by a man named
eric schmidt who is a top hillary
clinton supporter and donor
so i think that was a big operation the
beginning of the efforts they saw
trump's enemies that he was making
inroads with the public despite their
control of the news
and they saw that they had to do or
thought they had to do something about
the internet because they blamed the
internet
for the rise of trump outside of this
controlled news information landscape
trump took over the fake news phrase
being the master marketer that he is i
call it
a hostile takeover every time they cried
fake news he just like threw it back at
him
you're fake news and pretty soon he was
so good at it
that by january following the september
when this started
the washington post was printing
articles that were saying things like
it's time to retire the term fake news
you know they didn't like how it's being
used now by trump
yeah yes there she seems to be uh
uh i can't see where you are i'm sorry
i'm right over here we have a question
uh in the back in the back to the back
left of this okay okay
hi there thank you for being here there
seems to be a
virus um among our media particularly
even in conservative media lately to
even
question the validity of the election
um i'm noticing it on talk radio and
it's almost as if they will not
even bring it up and they deflect it
when anyone calls in
and i i'm assuming we know what happens
right and i'm
i'm just wondering um is it a matter of
maybe buying time
till we have some more um
secure platforms to be more honest i
mean is is this
perhaps what's going on or are we
relegated to just
this very limited narrative
for fear of of being cancelled it's a
good question
and i think we should all be cognizant
of not
being bullied out of using our common
sense making our own solutions seeking
out answers and various sides to stories
and saying what we think
you know my own view is only that which
is illegal should be censored and the
rest is fair game it's up to us to
figure out what we want to believe
and by the way if we want to believe
something that's false we have a right
to do that in this country
you know it's not up to somebody else to
say well you shouldn't be
thinking such things or talking about
such things
but being an optimist and i've talked to
some people who are looking for
solutions
i think there will be something that
fleshes out in the next four years
because
as i like to say the truth finds a way
to be told
and over history and over time when
people have been suppressed and their
views have been suppressed they've
always found a way
at least in this country to express how
they feel
and there are people working on the
challenges from three standpoints
there are investors who do want to
invest
in fair reporting and open information
so the money is there they just don't
know where to put it
but number two there are people that are
trying to accomplish the
question or the task of how do you not
get de-platformed
and they're trying to invent ways
outside big tech you know sort of like
we're addicts we got hooked on big tech
when they weren't trying to do this
censorship we thought it was wonderful
and now we all communicate that way and
they've sort of
done this bait and switch now they can
control us because we're all relying on
them
and they're changing the rules well
there are ways involving
far beyond my understanding but
involving things like blockchain
technology there are ways to design
platforms that can't be
so controlled by what we consider big
tech media there are people working on
that problem too
and then there are news people like me
who want to report
in a open way showing different
viewpoints and different scientific
studies and different opinions
so those three things i think will come
together somehow in the next four years
or so
and there will be new emerging
technologies and solutions
but i would say in the meantime we have
to be we have to work really hard not to
be bullied out of
being americans and being heard whatever
we think and whatever we feel
in a particularly when you're you talk
about the election to criminalize
feelings and thoughts about something as
important as the election
even when you're using common sense and
calling into question some things that
happen and
then to be treated like or told that
you're practically a criminal for
thinking that
or for expressing that this is a very
dangerous thing
and i hope we don't allow it
we have we have time for one more
question
uh it's really not a question it's more
of an acknowledgement
as soon as your book first book came out
i read it and loved it
then when you announced the second book
i got an early copy
and as soon as i got it i read it and
i'm a big fan
just want you to know that you're a
person who is intellectually honest
and has the courage to tell the truth
despite
all the crap that you're getting from
the media
i want to acknowledge you for being here
you're one of the reasons
i came here today and this weekend thank
you thank you
thank you very much thanks everybody